This is a scandal!
I go out
just here from the European Parliament's program,
of the vote of
2 new
free trade agreements with Kenya and Chile
that the European Parliament
has just adopted.
And so we'll end up importing chicken,
beef,
olive oil,
apples,
grapes,
Chile,
green beans or uh.
Flowers from Kenya.
But it's not like you can't produce
all this here,
in France and in Europe.
And reality,
is that here, eh,
on these bands of mystics,
sociodemocrats,
liberals,
the right,
uh of the extreme right,
there were members from each group
to vote on these agreements.
The same MPs who went
a few days ago
at the bedside of farmers
to tell them that,
we will help you,
uh.
We'll protect you from the competition,
from the loyal ones,
tell consumers that we will
uh protect European production.
And the reality,
well,
they are hypocrites and liars
because my group here has been
the only one not to support these 2 new agreements.
And it's nothing
in relation to the list of agreements that awaits us
with uh.
The mercossour,
with uh India,
uh.
With uh Mexico.
In short,
it's a madness
and we must stop this madness of free trade.
So we count on you to give voice,
to hold all these hypocrites accountable
who argued uh.
This agreement and the.
is that the question that will be asked on the new/06
next for the European elections
is it stop?
Or for us it's stop,
the planet
is not a large supermarket in which you will dive
our farmers
and in the process the survival of the planet by talking.